يوما بعد يوم تتجدد كل الاسئله الحائره
المتعلقه بمالات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وقد مرت تسعه اشهر على اندلاعها
تبرز المساعد دبلوماسيه التركيه في هذا
الصدر الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بحث هاتفيه
مع نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
والاوكراني
الجوارب السلبيه لاطاله امد الحرب
ويظنك
في محيط الازمه ظهرت مع تمديد اتفاق
الحبوب في البحر الاسود قبل يومين لمده
اربعه اشهر والذي تم توقيعه في يوليو
الماضي برعايه الامم المتحده وجهود تركيه
مباشره وغير مباشره ولا طالما عبر الرئيس
التركي منذ لقائه بنظره الاوكراني والامين
العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو غوتيرش في مدينه الفيف غربي
اوكرانيا عن ضروره الاستفاده من المناخ
الايجابي الذي يوفره اتفاق الحبوب للبحث
عن سبل التوسل لانهاء الحرب في اطار البحث
عن الحل السياسي المنشود تتحرك تركيا
حاليا ضمن مسارين مع موسكو واشنطن ووجه
الرئيس اردوغان الانذار صوبا لقاءات
الاخيره التي استضافتها بلاده بين مسؤول
المخابرات الروسيه والامريكيه وتعول على
استمرارها على الاقل لتقريب المواقف
المتباعده جدا حتى الان
روسيا رفضت على لسان نائب وزير الخارج
الافصاح عن تفاصيل ذلك الاجتماع
الاستخبارات الذي تم في تركيا
ان الحوار مع
عنصر مهم وقوي في اي مفاوضات مع اوكرانيا
ويقول ان كيف تنفذ توجيهات الغرب بدقه
هناك على ان خيار التفاوض ووقته قرار
الاوكراني وكييف قليله الحديث في هذا
الصدر
التركيه لكنه يكرر كثيرا اهميه وضع حد لما
يصفه بالاستفزازات الروسيه وسياسه التدبير
المنهج الذي تنفذها روسيا في بلاده واكتفى
في اتصال الجمعه مع اردوغان على تاكيد
ضمان بلاده للامن الغذائي العالمي نعم
هناك جهود تركيه مبذوله تجد الدعم ولو على
استحياء من الولايات المتحده ولكن من
السابق للاوائل الجزم بامكانيه اجراء
مفاوضات سلسه تعين على انهاء حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا